PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
BASED ON A HOAX THAT THEY IMPART
CREATED AND PERPETRATED ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY THINK THEY KNOW BETTER THAN
US, WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SMELLY WALMART PEOPLE ARE
REDEEMABLE DEPLORABLE'S AND
PEOPLE THAT CLING TO GOD,
BIBLES, RELIGION AND GUNS.
WE HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE BECAUSE THE
FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY IS AT
STAKE AND THAT IS NOT HYPERBOLE.
JOINING US NOW FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA JOE DiGENOVA AND
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
EMMA FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARA
CARTER, BUT JOE WE WILL BEGIN
WITH YOU.
WHERE WE ARE TODAY BECAUSE I
THINK THE STEELE ANNOUNCEMENT
YOU WILL START TALKING COULD
BLOW THIS PART OF IT WIDE OPEN.
>> Joe: HE'S OBVIOUSLY MADE A
STRATEGIC DECISION BECAUSE HE
WILL BE INTERVIEWED BY JOHN
DURHAM.
IT IS NOT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WHO WILL TALK TO HIM BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY REASON TO TALK
TO MR. HARO WITS.
HE WILL TALK TO JOHN DURHAM AND
HIS PEOPLE.
SO OBVIOUSLY SOME SORT OF DEAL
THAT HAS BEEN WORKED OUT.
THIS IS GREAT NEWS.
BUT ACCORDING TO SOME REPORTS,
THERE ARE LIMITATIONS ON THE
TESTIMONY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT DURHAM
WOULD AGREE TO LIMITATIONS.
BUT THIS IS WHAT IS IMPORTANT.
HE HAS TO TELL THE TRUTH TO
DURHAM BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH HIS
TESTIMONY WILL BE GIVEN
OVERSEAS, HE CAN BE INDICTED IN
THE UNITED STATES IF HE LIES TO
DURHAM.
I ASSUME HE WILL TELL THE TRUTH
BECAUSE THIS IS THE BIG, THIS IS
THE BIG CASINO NOW.
WHAT HE WILL PROVE IS THAT THE
FBI LIGHT INTO FISA WARRANTS AND
LIED TO CONGRESS AND THEY LIE TO
EVERYBODY ABOUT WHAT THEY KNEW
ABOUT STEELE'S BEHAVIOR.
THE WALLS ARE BEGINNING TO CLOSE
IN ON THE FBI FRAUDSTERS.
>> Sean: OKAY, WE TALK SARAH
LET ABOUT AN AVALANCHE CASCADING
DOWN BUT ONLY A SMALL PART.
BY THE WAY WHAT IS TAKING
MICHAEL HOROWITZ, 700 PEOPLE
WORKING FOR HIM BUT WHEN DO WE
GET THE PFIZER REPORT FINISHED
AND COMPLETED OR IS IT POSSIBLE
THAT HE'S COMPLETED IT AND
HANDED IT OVER TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND WE DON'T KNOW.
VICTORIOUS I KNOW BUT WHY
VICTORIA?
>> I THINK HE'S RUNNING INTO
DIFFICULTY TO GET DOCUMENTS FROM
CHRIS RAY OF THE FBI.
SO THAT WILL PROLONG HIS
INQUIRY.
THAT IS ABOUT WHAT HE CAN DO AN
HE CAN'T SUBPOENA ANYBODY AND HE
CAN'T INDICT ANYBODY.
>> Sean: HE CAN MAKE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS, CAN HE NOT?
>> Sara: HE ABSOLUTELY CAN.
I THINK VICTORIA IS RIGHT ON THE
MONEY.
HE IS HAVING DIFFICULTY.
WE KNOW THAT HE DOES HAVE 700
INVESTIGATORS, BUT REMEMBER,
SEAN MICHAEL HOROWITZ IS NOT
JUST FOCUSED ON THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION ALTHOUGH THAT IS
THE MAIN INVESTIGATION HIS TEAMS
WORKING ON.
THEY ARE WORKING ON A VARIETY OF
INVESTIGATIONS.
SO THIS IS TAKING UP THE BULK OF
HIS TIME.
EVERY DAY, WE GET SOMETHING NEW
OR AT LEAST I DO IN MY EMAIL BOX
FROM THE INSPECTOR GENERAL ON
OTHER ISSUES THEY ARE WORKING
ON.
AS FOR CHRISTOPHER STEELE, I
THINK WHAT IS SO SIGNIFICANT
HERE, IS THAT HE PROBABLY WORKED
OUT AN IMMUNITY DEAL BEFORE
COMING HERE BEFORE MAKING ANY
STATEMENTS TO INVESTIGATORS OR
TO THE PROSECUTOR WHETHER THAT
BE JOHN DURHAM OR SOMEBODY ELSE
THAT THEY HAVE IN MIND.
SO THINK ABOUT THAT.
IF HE DID CUT AN IMMUNITY DEAL,
THAT MEANS HE PROBABLY HAS A LOT
TO SAY.
>> Sean: BUT THE THING IS,
HE'S ALREADY BEEN QUESTION ON
ALL OF THEM.
WHEN PUSH CAME TO SHOVE, JOE, HE
HAD TO TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT THE
DOSSIER, HE RAN FROM IT,
OTHERWISE, HE WOULD BE HELD ON
PERJURY CHARGE.
HIS ANSWER WAS CLEAR THAT HE
NEVER VERIFIED IT.
HE HAD NO IDEA IF ANY OF IT WAS
TRUE 50/50 RAW INTELLIGENCE BUT
MEANWHILE THE FBI PAYING HIM,
HE'LL REPAYING HIM AND DNC
PAYING HIM ALL FOR THE SAME
LIES.
AND IT DID GET DISSEMINATED BY
THE LIKES OF WATT, BRENNAN,
CLAPPER AND WHO ELSE MAY HAVE
PUSHED THAT PROPAGANDA OUT TO
THE AMERICAN MEDIA THAT JUST
GULLIBLE AND HUNGRY FOR ANYTHING
THAT HURT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Joe: THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
STEELE IN HIS DEPOSITION AND THE
LONDON LIBEL CASE FILED AGAINST
HIM MADE IT CLEAR THAT HE HAD
NOT VERIFIED THE INFORMATION IN
THE DOSSIER.
THAT IT WAS ALL UNVERIFIED.
THAT HE COULDN'T VOUCH FOR IT,
AND THEREFORE, IT IS PRETTY
OBVIOUS THAT HE PROBABLY TOLD
THE SAME THING TO THE FBI.
AND THAT THE FBI KNEW THAT IT
WAS MERELY A COVER PIECE FOR
THEM TO USE TO TRY TO GET CARTER
PAGE AND PAPADOPOULOS AND
MICHAEL FLYNN AND EVERYBODY
ELSE.
LISTEN, MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT
IT.
THE FBI AT THE JAMES COMEY LEVEL
AND SENIOR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
UNDER OBAMA ENGAGED IN A
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHILE HE WAS A
CANDIDATE, WHILE HE WAS
PRESIDENT-ELECT AND WHILE HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
THAT IS WHY JOHN DURHAM WANTS TO
TALK TO HIM.
BECAUSE THERE WAS A CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY LED BY SENIOR FBI
OFFICIALS.
AND I JUST HOPE ALL OF THEM,
McCABE, JAMES COMEY, ALL OF
THEM BAKER, JUST KEEP TALKING
PUBLICLY.
JUST KEEP TALKING.
>> Sean: THAT IS THE SINGLE
MOST ASKED QUESTION I GET.
IF YOU ARE NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE,
WE DON'T HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING CALLED
JUSTICE.
>> Joe: I COULD NOT AGREE WITH
YOU MORE.
>> Victoria: SEAN I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A LITTLE POINT ABOUT
STEELE AND THAT IS ALL WE HAVE
HEARD AGAIN AND AGAIN HE IS A
CREDIBLE PERSON A CREDIBLE
SOURCE.
I PRACTICE LAW AS AN ASSISTANT
U.S. ATTORNEY FOR FIVE YEARS AND
THIS IS FOURTH AMENDMENT LAW.
YOU DON'T CARE IF A COP TELLS
YOU SOMETHING IS A GOOD PERSON